vers craag il ya quelques instants
depuis kiev la barre des quatre millions
de réfugiés a été franchi 4 millions
d'ukrainiens qui ont quitté leur pays en
35 jours l'europe n'avait plus connu de
tel flot de réfugiés depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale bonjour pauline godard
on vous retrouve en direct à la
frontière avec la pologne vous êtes à
medica précisément où l'exode se
poursuit
oui les réfugiés continuent à flûtes a
fait ici tous les jours alors il est
vrai que ces trois derniers jours ce
refus de réfugiés étaient légèrement en
baisse mais selon les derniers chiffres
fournis par les autorités polonaises et
bien ces dernières 24 heures ce chiffre
est légèrement monté puisqu'il est
environ 5000 personnes et qui ont
franchi la frontière et si nous ça fait
à peu près une semaine que nous sommes
ici et nous constatons bien sûr
évidemment que ces personnes arrivent en
pologne mais également repartent en
ukraine viennent ici parfois juste se
reposer pendant quelques jours trouver
un endroit où elles peuvent mettre
certains membres de leur famille en
sécurité et puis elles repartent
certaines de serre personnes nous ont
expliqué certaines ong bien que ces
personnes en fait décidé de retourner en
ukraine puisqu'elle y avait laissé
parfois leurs parents leurs parents
leurs grands parents des personnes âgées
des personnes parfois invalides malades
qui ne peuvent pas venir jusqu'ici et
nous ont dit et bien qu'il préférait si
que s'il devait mourir et bien au moins
ils mourraient auprès d'eux comment ça
s'organise pauline sur place il y a des
milliers d'associations domaine j'ai
peut-être un peu trop
oui ça c'est vrai qu'il ya énormément de
ng tout le monde ici veut pouvoir aider
tous ces réfugiés qui arrivent on voit
énormément de réfugiés énormément de
bénévoles en fait il faut savoir qu'une
fois que les réfugiés ont passé la
frontière qui se trouve juste derrière
moi ils ont le choix soit directement
d'être prises en charge et d'aller
prendre un bus qui les conduira dans un
centre de réfugiés ou bien ils peuvent
ici et bien prendre un café manger
quelque chose se reposer c'est vrai on
l'a vu la plupart des gens qui arrivent
ici ce sont en grande grande partie plus
de 90% des femmes et des enfants ils
arrivent ici souvent exténué puisqu'ils
ont marché pendant des jours ce pendant
des dizaines et des dizaines de
kilomètres ils doivent parfois attendre
jusqu'à 8 heures c'est arrivé de l'autre
côté de la frontière un du côté
ukrainien pour pouvoir passer ici donc
ça leur permet au moins de se reposer
tout est mis à disposition il est
absolument tout ici pour pouvoir tenter
un minimum de les aider et de leur
confort t ils peuvent également voir un
médecin nous avons passé avec du temps
avec un médecin français nous a expliqué
être ici confronté pour l'essentiel à
des cas de gastro-entérite par exemple
ou à des personnes et biens qui n'ont
plus leur traitement comme des personnes
diabétiques il y a aussi tout ce
problème au niveau des médicaments
puisque de nombreux médicaments sont
envoyés en ukraine 1 pour répondre à des
besoins des besoins des hôpitaux
français et ce médecin nous expliquer et
bien que pour pour s assurer que ces
médicaments arrivent bien à destination
et bien ils font tout pour tracer ces
médicaments ils prennent des photos et
on compte le nombre de boîtes certains
médicaments sont même cachet à certains
endroits dans certains cartons puisque
certains médicaments disparaissent comme
des médicaments pour la thyroïde et ils
sont ensuite revendus au marché noir est
bien le fait d'avoir mis tout ça en
place tout ce processus leur permet une
fois que les médicaments arrivent et
tous les cartons arrivé bien de vérifier
si le don de carton est bien là et que
des cartons n'ont pas disparu et ça leur
permet donc de savoir s'ils peuvent
toujours faire confiance au chauffeur à
qui ils ont confié ces médicaments merci
pauline godard pauline godard envoyé
spécial de france 24 à méditer à la
frontière entre la pologne et l'ukraine